en tout elle décrit la préparation et
l'exécution de 10 assassinats parmi ces
locataires Tamara serait une tueuse en
série
à quelques kilomètres de
Saint-Pétersbourg la deuxième ville de
Russie nous sommes à fruitzen ski une
cité dortoir bétonnée et grise vestiges
de l'époque soviétique comme tous les
immeubles russes cet édifice possède des
caméras de vidéosurveillance et en
juillet dernier elles ont capté un bien
étrange manège en pleine nuit une
vieille femme fait des allers-retours
dans la cage d'escalier
elle traîne vers la sortie des sacs trop
lourds pour elle
[Musique]
le lendemain les sacs sont découverts
éparpillés au pied des immeubles à
l'intérieur des morceaux de corps humain
Dimitri un voisin vient souvent pêcher
dans l'étang du coin sur le chemin il
découvre la scène macabre
[Musique]
il y avait des policiers qui bloquaient
l'accès
leur voiture était garée tout autour
je suis passé à côté j'ai vu des
morceaux de corps humain
ici il y avait un buste enveloppé dans
un rideau de douche
il y avait un autre morceau là
et encore un autre sac plus loin
la femme au sac est rapidement reconnue
grâce aux images de vidéosurveillance
c'est une habitante de l'immeuble elle a
68 ans elle s'appelle Tamara samsonova
la police l'arête immédiatement
les morceaux de corps sont identifiés il
s'agit de Valentina Oulanova 79 ans une
voisine de Tamara la presse russe
s'empare de l'affaire
la police du quartier de frutzinski
vient d'arrêter une retraité de 68 ans
elle est soupçonnée d'assassinat selon
les informations des enquêteurs elle a
tué une retraité dont elle s'occupait
elle a empoisonné découpé son corps en
morceaux et jeter les restes dans le
quartier la police craint qu'elle est
assassinée d'autres personnes
son propre mari et d'autres locataires
ont en effet aussi disparu au cours des
dernières années
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il dans cet immeuble qui
est Tamara pourquoi une partie de la
presse russe l'appel-t-elle la mamie
cannibale
la jeune Tamara a passé son enfance en
Sibérie à 17 ans elle part faire ses
études à 4000 km de là à Moscou elle y
apprend l'allemand à l'université début
70 elle devient assistante maternelle à
Saint-Pétersbourg à la même époque elle
épouse un ingénieur et s'installe avec
lui au sud de la ville dans cet immeuble
où elle aurait commis l'innommable
[Musique]
Tamara trouve ensuite du travail dans un
hôtel de luxe en plein centre-ville elle
y est concierge d’étage pendant 7 ans
avant d'enchaîner de petits boulots
jusqu'à sa retraite
Sacha est reporteur dans le journal le
plus populaire du pays le comme
somalskaïa Pravda elle a reconstitué
toute la vie de Tamara
[Musique]
on arrive à l'appartement où elle a vécu
plus de 40 ans
de ce palier ses fenêtres donnaient de
l'autre côté
Marina a été sa voisine de palier
pendant 10 ans et son ami aussi c'est
son appartement
les scellés de la police sont toujours
en place
pendant des années les deux femmes se
fréquentent sans que Marina ne remarque
rien d'anormal
la première fois que je l'ai rencontré
je l'ai trouvé très sympa très calme
elle m'a invité souvent à boire un café
elle adorait le café et puis on
discutait vraiment je le répète elle
donnait l'impression de quelqu'un de
tout à fait normal
une vie tranquille avec son mari sans
enfant sans relief sans problème jusqu'à
ce jour de 2005
son mari disparaît et quand ses voisins
lui demandaient où il était elle
répondait juste qu'il était parti
aujourd'hui encore malgré les recherches
de la police son mari reste introuvable
retraitée Tamara vit sur sa seule
pension de 10000 roubles par mois 150
euros elle cherche alors à améliorer
l'ordinaire après la disparition de son
mari elle a rapidement commencé à louer
une des deux chambres de l'appartement
d'après les voisins en l'espace de 10
ans il y a eu une centaine de locataires
les gens ne restaient jamais plus de
deux ou trois mois
ses voisins n'ont jamais rien remarqué
de suspect Tamara était très discrète
vous savez on ne la voyait pas beaucoup
elle partait tôt le matin et elle
revenait le soir elle avait l'air un peu
bizarre quand même
effectivement depuis quelques mois
Tamara se met à avoir un comportement
instable elle devient agressive si
agressive quand en février dernier ses
voisins arrivent à la faire interner
dans cet hôpital psychiatrique
mais deux mois plus tard les médecins la
laissent sortir
marina se souvient de son retour dans
l'immeuble elle était très perturbée
en la revoyant j'ai été vraiment
surprise déjà c'était en plein jour
alors qu'elle vivait la nuit d'habitude
je promenais mon chien et je l'ai vu
qu'il marchait comme une furie elle est
passée sous le porche et elle a disparu
j'ai immédiatement compris que quelque
chose avait basculé dans sa tête son
comportement était très inhabituel
Tamara ne veut plus voir Marina ni ses
autres voisins qui l'ont dénoncé en mai
elle déménage dans l'immeuble que l'on
voit à droite de l'image à 300 mètres de
son ancien appartement
elle s'installe chez Valentina une
retraité de 79 ans la future victime
[Musique]
nous sommes deux mois avant son
assassinat la meilleure amie de la
défunte Natalia se souvient avec émotion
de leur amitié
Valentina était quelqu'un de joyeux de
dynamique qui aimait la compagnie qui
aimait célébrer les fêtes
je se promenais ensemble tous les matins
et le soir aussi elle aimait se balader
en ville
très vite elle croise Tamara chez son
ami et celle-ci ne lui inspire pas du
tout confiance elle a même un terrible
pressentiment
[Musique]
vous savez je m'inquiétais tellement que
j'ai demandé à Valentina de me faire un
signe tous les matins juste pour moi
je lui demandais d'accrocher ses rideaux
de façon différente chaque jour pour que
je sache que tout allait bien sans que
j'ai besoin de la déranger
mais le pire va se produire des tensions
apparaissent entre les deux femmes
Valentina la propriétaire aurait eu
l'intention d'expulser Tamara qui ne
l'aurait pas supporté
c'est alors qu'elle aurait mis à
exécution son plan diabolique pour se
débarrasser de Valentina comme elle a
fini par l'avouer à la police ce soir de
juillet il est environ 22h Tamara
prépare le dîner dans la cuisine dans la
salade elle verse une boîte entière
d'insomnifère très puissant ce jour-là
l'ambiance est détendue les deux
voisines semblent réconcilier elles
boivent de la vodka ensemble mais très
vite le mélange fait son effet
Valentina s'effondre sur le sol de la
cuisine
en pleine nuit Tamara aurait alors
démembré à l'aide d'une scie le corps de
sa victime inconsciente mais toujours
vivante et comble de l'horreur elle
aurait fait bouillir sa tête et ses
mains dans une casserole
voilà pourquoi elle se fera appeler
mamie cannibale mais Tamara n'a jamais
mangé de chéruben elle a raconté à la
police qu'elle avait fait bouillir la
tête pour empêcher toute identification
elle a mis les restes de son ami dans
des sacs en plastique et deux jours plus
tard seulement elle commence son étrange
balai devant les caméras de surveillance
la tête de sa victime elle va la
descendre dans la casserole comme elle
le racontera aux enquêteurs pour ensuite
l'abandonner à quelques dizaines de
mètres de là
de son côté Natalia s'inquiète de ne
voir aucun signe à la fenêtre
quand j'ai vu que les rideaux ne
bougeaient plus je suis allé à son
appartement Tamara aussitôt ouvert la
porte je lui ai demandé où était
Valentina et elle a répondu je ne sais
pas elle est peut-être partie
quand son mari avait disparu elle avait
eu la même réponse
Tamara sera arrêté par la police 24
heures seulement après s'être
débarrassée du corps elle pensait avoir
déconnecté toutes les caméras de
vidéosurveillance mais elle en avait
oublié deux
son appartement est fouillé de fond en
comble et l'affaire connaît un
rebondissement inattendu les policiers
découvrent plusieurs carnets écrits en
allemand le journal intime de Tamara son
contenu fait froid dans le dos le
moindre geste de sa vie quotidienne y a
consigné méthodiquement elle numérote
toutes ses actions 9 je dors bien je
bois du café 12 je me lève à 6h du matin
j'ai lu un livre mais le soir je ne me
sens pas bien 21 je fais mes petites
affaires
28 je me lève à 5h du matin je me lave
la tête j'ai de l'argent 13 + 10 + 700
mais il y a pire Sacha la journaliste a
eu accès à l'ensemble du journal intime
elle raconte notamment le meurtre d'un
homme
qui était elle indique la date le nom de
famille et la description d'un grand
tatouage qu'il avait sur le bras tout
est noté les policiers ont retrouvé la
famille de cet homme et ils se sont
rendus compte qu'il avait bien vécu chez
Tamara l'année de sa disparition et
c'est à cette même époque que les restes
humains avaient déjà été retrouvés dans
le quartier
en tout elle décrit la préparation et
l'exécution de 10 assassinats parmi ces
locataires Tamara serait une tueuse en
série
mais lors d'une audience devant le
tribunal de Saint-Pétersbourg elle ne
reconnaît que trois meurtres dont celui
de son mari disparu depuis 10 ans sans
laisser de trace et puis elle se
rétracte
exceptionnellement le tribunal a laissé
entrer des caméras pour l'une des
audiences Tamara va s'adresser
directement au journaliste dans son box
elle semble délirer elle accuse
désormais une mystérieuse personne qui
l'aurait harcelé
je veux vivre en prison
et pourquoi vous voulez vivre en prison
parce que je suis harcelée par une
maniaque qui m'a rendu folle et m'a
poussé au meurtre
c'était une voisine
elle me harcelait elle était docteur et
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous faisait
[Musique]
ce qui est possible et imaginable
elle me tirait les cheveux
elle me frappait jusqu'au bleu elle me
la serrait les mains elle me brisait les
genoux
il y a beaucoup de témoins des personnes
de l'église les services sociaux
beaucoup d'autres vous en parleront
mensonge hallucination il n'y a aucun
témoin et la police ne retrouve pas ce
mystérieux personnage une dernière
question pourquoi avez-vous fait tout ça
pour échapper à cette maniaque
Tamara n'aurait-elle pas toute sa raison
pour son avocate en tout cas elle
pourrait ne pas être déclarée
responsable de ses actes d'ailleurs pour
certains experts le fait de numéroter
tous ces faits et gestes comme elle le
fait dans son journal intime est un
signé évident de troubles psychiatriques
il faut que les experts se penchent de
nouveau sur son cas on parle de
schizophrénie en fonction du diagnostic
on pourra savoir si elle peut être
soignée dans ce cas elle pourrait être
internée ou même suivre des soins à
domicile c'est une décision qui pourrait
être prise même avant tout procès
Tamara n'est pour l'instant accusé que
du seul meurtre de Valentina l'enquête
risque de durer très longtemps les
policiers recherchent ces anciens
locataires il se penchent sur les
disparition inexpliquées tamara est
enfermé derrière ses murs dans un centre
psychiatrique pénitencier de
Saint-Pétersbourg si elle est jugée apte
pour un procès elle risque entre 15 ans
de prison et la perpétuité